thank you all for coming this morning
we're eager to dive right into our topic
because it's a topic that is of great
consequence for the future of the of the
country and indeed the the world in
which we live thank you for joining
Hillsdale College this morning for our
first principles on First Fridays
lecture series my name is David Bob I
direct the LNP Kirby jr. center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
this is a program of Hillsdale College
that is based in Washington DC were
dedicated to the same thing that
Hillsdale College has been dedicated to
since its founding in 1844 and that's
the education of particularly young
people undergraduates but also anyone
who's who's interested in willing to to
think hard about things like the history
the political thought the foundations of
this country you can find out more about
the kirby center in our mission online
we have a number of programs and we'll
be launching a number of lecture series
in addition to this one in the coming
months you can find that information at
the kirby center ki rby center.org this
morning's Washington Post has the
headline Obama aids near reversal on 911
trial now as our speaker this morning
Andrew McCarthy will tell us sometimes
you have to be wary even of the
Washington Post headlines
we're really thrilled that the Thai Andy
can join us this morning he has a
tremendous record I'm sure that many of
you have read him he's already posted
this morning and he's already done a
studio appearance at Fox News he's been
just a real leader in educating
Americans about the topic that we're
looking at this morning that topic is
America's war on terror or is it joining
me this morning to introduce our speaker
is hillsdale college student Jason
Statler Jason is part of the Washington
Hillsdale internship program whip for
short whip has been around for about 35
years and has sent hundreds of hillsdale
college students over those years to
Washington DC where they serve full-time
internships take a couple of classes and
engage in a series of co-curricular
activities like going to Gettysburg and
and all the many wonderful sights and
things to explore in Washington DC Jason
is gaining experience in his full-time
internship at the American Trucking
Association he's a political science
major a junior and will now introduce
our speaker Jason good morning Andrew
see McCarthy is a senior fellow at the
National Review Institute a contributing
editor at National Review and
co-chairman of the Center for Law and
counterterrorism a joint project of
National Review Institute in the
foundation for defense of democracies he
is the author of The New York Times
bestseller willful blindness memoir of
the jihad his next book the grand jihad
how Islam in the Left sabotage America
will be published by encounter this year
for 18 years mr. McCarthy was an
assistant united states attorney in the
Southern District of New York from 1993
through 1995 he was the lead prosecutor
in the terrorism case against Sheikh
Omar Abdel Rahman and 11 others in
connection with the 1993 World Trade
Center bombing and plot to bomb the New
York City landmarks
he served the office in several
executive staff positions supervising
the training of new prosecutors in
preparation of briefs and arguments
before the United States Court of
Appeals following the 911 attacks he
supervised the Justice Department's
command post near Ground Zero in New
York City in 2004 he served the Pentagon
as special assistant to the deputy the
Secretary of Defense mr. McCarthy has
been an adjunct professor at both New
York law school and fordham university
school of law he is the recipient of
numerous awards including the justice
department's highest honors in addition
to being featured regularly in the
National Review his articles have
appeared in The Wall Street Journal the
New York Times commentary the Weekly
Standard the American Spectator in many
other publications this morning mr.
McCarthy will speak on the topic
America's war on terror where is it
please join me in welcoming Andrew
McCarthy
well thank you so much it's a it's a
great honor to be here this morning
David was good enough to to mention all
my great accomplishments of of just this
morning Fox News and getting a post up
on the corner what he didn't tell you
was this great leader of men made the
wrong turn coming out of the hotel this
morning and went about three blocks out
of my way so I've also had my run as it
turns out you would think that being in
a hotel only about four blocks away
would not be a major catastrophe but
there you have it I do want to talk a
little bit later maybe when we get to
questions maybe at some point about the
article in The Washington Post this
morning because I actually do think it's
it's something of a head fake but we can
we can talk about that what I want to
first do though is address the topic I
was was asked to address which is
America's war on terror or is it I want
to begin with a story from early in
American history you are hereby
commanded to show cause the general
studied this document in his hands it
was a writ of habeas corpus issued by an
American Court a federal judge was
presuming in the midst of war to order
the commander in a combat theater to
report to the courthouse the following
morning and explain himself on what
basis the judge demanded to know was the
United States Army holding a prisoner of
war habeas corpus you shall have the
body it is known as the Great Red an
eighth century old creature of the Magna
Carta of British common law of Western
enlightenment tradition it was first
formally established in the colonies in
the 1690s about 85 years before the
Declaration of Independence when the
Constitution was adopted in 1787 it
became
of our fundamental law enshrined in
what's called the Suspension Clause
article 1 section 9 of the Constitution
which says the privilege of the writ of
habeas corpus shall not be suspended
unless when in cases of rebellion or
invasion the public safety may require
it the writ in short is our time-honored
bulwark against tyranny but tell that to
Louis Whaler and while you're at it tell
that to the Honorable Dominic Augustine
Hall the united states district judge in
louisiana louisiana had only been estate
for about three years when in early 1815
the commanding general in question
Andrew Jackson authorized the arrest and
detention of Lewis Luella the late great
chief justice william h Rehnquist told
the story in his gripping book about
civil liberties in wartime all the laws
but one old hickory had just saved the
Republic by defeating British the
British forces of General Sir Edward
parking ham in the decisive battle of
new orleans it doesn't do the victory
justice to say that Jackson had won the
war of 1812 the Treaty of Ghent which
formally concluded the war had actually
been signed by British and American
foreign ministers over two weeks earlier
but news of the treaty did not reach the
United States in time to forestall the
battle it became the one great American
victory of the war of 1812 just as
Jackson hadn't known about the formal
armistice so too he did not know what
the British would do with their defeated
army would they regroup and attempt
another assault with the outcome and
survival itself still in doubt Jackson
imposed martial law he was determined to
maintain it until he knew for sure that
hostilities were over this did not
please mister Liu weiler he took to the
newspapers to attack Jackson and
Jackson's imposition of martial military
law and order perceiving this as a very
untimely incitement Jackson had Luella
arrested aroused cipal
orders of Lou iler the imprisoned man
appealed to judge Hall the jurist like
any jurist had utterly no responsibility
for the national security of the United
States the framers intended that
national security decisions be made by
elected officials accountable to the
voters whose lives are at stake the
judges only duty was to ensure that the
litigants before him received due
process because that Duty is a limited
one judge Hall like all federal judges
was politically insulated in executing
it yet the judge was of a mind that he
not the United States Army personified
the rule of law security were no
security General Jackson was of a
different mind instead of responding to
the writ as directed at eleven o'clock
the next morning Jackson had Justice
Hall arrested after a time he had him
escorted by troops several miles outside
the city limits where he was finally set
free I think it's fair to say that we've
come a long way from Andrew Jackson to
Barack Obama and I think it's probably
even fair to say that we've come an even
longer way from Lewis Luella to Omar
Farouk Abdulmutallab the Christmas
bomber it's become fashionable in this
era of hope and change to invoke the
rule of law that phrase in quotes as if
it meant the rule of lawyers and in
particular the rule of robed lawyers
that however has never been the terms
meaning nor could it be in any Republic
that hope to stand the test of time yes
we are always beholden to the rule of
law in the United States however the
rule of law is embodied by the
Constitution embodied not personified
the rule of law consists of the
Constitution and the statutes treaties
rules and regulations adopted pursuant
to it the rule of law does not refer to
the government officials who apply or
purport to apply the Constitution
whether they are judges or officers of
the political branches these officials
are our servants
the Constitution servants they are not
our rulers it has also been trendy in
recent years especially among our legal
elites to de claimed an all do piety
that the Constitution is not quote
suspended in wartime suspended by the
way is a clever choice of words it's an
attempt to trace the lineage of this
absurd statement that the Constitution
is not suspended in more time to the
great writ of habeas corpus and to the
diction of our fundamental law of the
Constitution of course no one who
believes that our nation has a natural
right to defend itself believes the
Constitution is ever suspended the
constitution is not however nor has it
ever been the imposition of judicial
rule indeed the Constitution imposes
strict limitations on the judicial power
just as it does on the powers of other
government actors it has never been the
case that where judicial power ends
anarchy begins General Andrew Jackson
may have been wrong to lock up Louis
Luella in fact a military court that was
set up to try Luella actually ended up
quitting him of inciting mutiny and
insurrection still Jackson was not wrong
in determining that with it that it was
his decision to make not as a tyrant but
within the constraints of military
protocols we were not in peacetime and
in fact the moment formal word of the
Treaty of Ghent reached New Orleans
Jackson immediately reinstated civilian
rule but until that time the civilian
courts were not responsible for keeping
order in New Orleans they were in that
time of crisis inadequate to that task
unless you think justice hall and his
stack of writs were a match for His
Majesty's Armed Forces then thought to
be the mightiest on earth General
Jackson was applying a principle stated
with clarity almost a century later by
Oliver Wendell Holmes jr. a legendary
Supreme Court justice and progressive
thinker but also a decorated veteran of
the Civil War as Holmes put it writing
for a unanimous court I believe in 19
own
9 when it comes to a decision by the
head of the state upon a matter
involving its life the ordinary rights
of individuals must yield to what he
deems the necessities of the moment
public danger warns the substitution of
executive process for judicial process
when the life of the state is imperiled
the Constitution does not disappear it
adapts in times of armed conflict it
imposes the laws and customs of war
which are every bit as much a part of
the rule of law as judicial processes
are in peacetime on this point it's
worth pausing to remember why we have a
constitution after independence our new
country had tried to survive and thrive
under the Articles of Confederation and
perpetual Union the experiment was a
failure for many reasons but paramount
was its construct of national security
by committee that turned out to be very
ineffective security indeed it allowed
England to ignore its treaty commitments
Spain to choke off the Mississippi River
and US flags loo at us flagships to be
besieged by the Barbary pirates in
america's first experience with Islamist
terror as you may know that's how we got
the US Marines from the halls of
Montezuma to the shores of Tripoli the
Constitution remedied this potential
potentially fatal weakness of the
Articles of Confederation it endowed all
executive authority including the powers
of commander-in-chief in a single
government official the President of the
United States our fundamental law was
conceived and adopted this way with
powers that could be awesome in
confronting threats precisely because
the framers knew a basic point that
seems lost on us today the United States
is not necessarily forever the rights we
cherish the freedoms that define us as
Americans would be little more than
parchment promises unless we could
defend ourselves and defeat our enemies
moreover unlike today's left the
founders understood that we would always
have enemies real enemies not as Mark
Steyn memorably member
we put syd just friends whose grievances
we haven't yet accommodated we would not
be able to define our enemies out of
existence by not uttering their names we
would not be able to rationalize them
out of existence by insisting that their
hostility is somehow our fault and
therefore within our power to reverse if
only we would change ourselves and we
most certainly would not be able to
indict them into submission in our
civilian courts we would have to defeat
them which meant we would have to be
able to enforce the protocols necessary
to wage war successfully these protocols
are the laws of war they are older than
the United States they are common-sense
defense measures requiring combatants to
wear uniforms to carry their weapons
openly to be part of a regular armed
force and most importantly to refrain
from intentionally targeting civilians
they also define wartime powers and
privileges enemy combatants for example
may be captured and detained until the
conclusion of hostilities fighters who
adhere to the laws of war are honorable
combatants privileged to use force and
entitled to various protections upon
CAPTCHA by contrast fighters who flout
the laws of war such as non-uniform
terrorists who target and savage
civilians are unlawful combatants they
are not privileged to use force they are
not entitled to the protections of
honorable soldiers and they may be
prosecuted by military commission if
they commit war crimes this is every bit
a legal system but it is not a judicial
system and it is not intended to be
throughout our history at least until
September 11 2001 we seem to know that
chief justice rehnquist book was called
all the laws but one as an homage to
Abraham Lincoln it has been widely noted
by the left's legions since nine eleven
that the Supreme Court ultimately
rejected President Lincoln's suspension
of habeas corpus to quell insurrections
during the Civil War not as often
mentioned is the fact that Congress
actually endorsed Lincoln's action when
it returned to session
remember those were the good old days
when Congress was an in session while
that often also overlooked is the fact
that the legal question before the
Supreme Court was a very close call the
Suspension Clause only says when habeas
corpus may be suspended it does not tell
us who has the power to do the
suspending Chief Justice Roger Taney
concluded in a case called ex parte
merryman that because the framers
located the suspension clause in article
1 which defines the powers of Congress
rather than article 2 which defines the
powers of the President it must have
been understood by the framers to be a
power of Congress not a power of the
president that's a reasonable
interpretation but it's hardly
indisputable and there was something far
more implausible in the case than
President Lincoln's belief that he had
the power to suspend the writ as long as
the conditions that are laid out in the
Constitution had been satisfied it was
Tani's claim this is the the thing I
think was more implausible Tani's
claimed that if the courts were open and
functioning even in wartime federal
judges not the political branches
responsible for prosecuting the war
would have the final word on what
actions could be taken in the defense of
the United States that contention has no
support in our founding law it was a
power grab pure and simple and a foolish
and undemocratic one at that most missed
however has been Lincoln's explanation
for his action at the time the very
survival of our union hung in the
balance with Confederate sympathizers
sabotaging railways and otherwise
impeding Union forces from reaching the
battlefield it is for just these
exigencies that we have a suspension
clause as President Lincoln eloquently
reasoned in a message to a special
session of Congress on july 4th 1861 if
the writ of habeas corpus fashioned with
such extreme tenderness to the citizens
Liberty where as sacrosanct as tani
contended it would allow all the laws
but one to go on execute it and the
government itself to go to pieces
less that one be violated it's a
preposterous notion what if the
president's obligation to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution all
of it not just the writ of habeas corpus
what of the central purpose of
government to provide for the common
defense what becomes of the rights we
cherish if the structure so carefully
crafted to defend them vanishes these
were the challenges with which Lincoln
grappled and they were challenges with
which FDR grappled as well in the second
world war in June 1942 the dark hours of
World War two when the outcome was
anything but clear eight German
saboteurs were captured after landing
off the coasts of Long Island in Florida
they had been sent to the United States
by the Fuehrer himself to commit acts of
terrorism against civilian
infrastructure that was critical to our
war effort the commander-in-chief
decided to make an example of them FDR
wasn't interested in the fact that the
federal courts were open and functioning
nor was he swayed by the fact that one
of the saboteurs happen to be an
American citizen President Roosevelt
directed that they be detained without
civilian charge as enemy combatants and
further that they'd be tried by military
commission nor did FDR unlike today
perceive the need to festoon the
proceedings with the trappings of a
marshal setting the Commission took
place not at a military base in Cuba but
in an FBI conference room in what is now
the robert f kennedy Justice of the
Department of Justice building just a
few blocks away from where we're meeting
this morning the defense lawyers
naturally cried foul they filed a
petition for a writ of habeas corpus in
the supreme court claiming that the
military trial violated the Constitution
given that the courts were open and
functioning in the United States upon
hearing about the petition FDR the famed
progressive president summoned his
Attorney General Francis Biddle the
famed progressive civil libertarian FDR
told Biddle to communicate to Chief
Justice Harlan Fisk stone in no
uncertain terms that he didn't care what
the Supreme Court thought
the Constitution not him not the
justices I'm sorry the Constitution made
him not the justices responsible for the
national defense the lives of the
American people and the successful
prosecution of the war FDR said he would
not be releasing the prisoners
regardless of the Court's disposition of
the case this proved to be something of
a judicial King has no clothes moment a
moment of clarity such as we have not
had I would say in the ensuing
half-century plus the brute fact is
courts have no power to enforce their
readings the persuasive force that
induces that us to honor their rulings
is the perceived legitimacy of those
rulings FDR was willing to bet if it got
down to brass tacks that the American
people would decide the
commander-in-chief they had chosen the
president who would have to face them in
the next election was the government
official they wanted running the war and
protecting the country not a tribunal of
unelected lawyers whom they could not
remove if they got vital security
questions wrong in the event the Supreme
Court was also willing to bet that
Roosevelt was right in the famous case
of ex parte Kiran in 1942 the justices
somehow found it within themselves to
uphold everything FDR wanted to do and
in another store apart from today's
ambivalence about war the entire episode
from capture in june until the execution
of most of the saboteurs in august took
about seven weeks what is the real
difference between then and now how do
we go from Jackson and Lincoln and FDR
to the Obama administration stunning
mishandling of the so-called Christmas
bomber Umar Farouk Abdulmutallab recall
that the man who tried to detonate a
chemical bomb on an airplane an attack
that would have killed 288 innocents
aboard and an untold number of Americans
on the ground was a trained al Qaeda
operative we are in a congressionally
authorized state of war with that
transnational jihadist terror network
abdul mutalib was a nigerian national
sent from yemen to attack us he had no
claim on the protection of civilian due
process and no claim on the protection
of our constitution what's more our
intelligence community tells us that
Yemen is currently one of the prime
launch points of anti-american terrorism
in the world Abdulmutallab had spent
four months there he knew the training
camps the trainers the identities of
other terrorists evidently scores of
them who had been trained and are being
trained to carry out just the same kinds
of atrocities that he was trying to
carry out that is his capture alive
should have been one of the great
intelligence kuz of this war instead he
was questioned for a mere 50 minutes
before being given Miranda warnings and
the assistance of counsel he naturally
invoked his right who's supposed right
to remain silent and was consulted
consigned to the civilian justice system
he was charged in an indictment that
gave him plea bargaining leverage in any
further negotiations over whether he
would share with us what he knows about
al-qaeda operations this was completely
unnecessary optimal Talib could and
should have been designated as an enemy
combatant and interrogated without the
interference of a lawyer were the
complications of a criminal prosecution
even if one believed as the Obama
administration says it believes that it
is important to our reputation in the
world to endow him with all the rights
of the Americans he was trying to
slaughter there was no legal requirement
that that be done now he could have been
turned over to the civilian authorities
two or three or more years from now once
his intelligence reservoir was fully
tapped we'd have lost nothing but the
ability to introduce any confession that
he made at trial and any competent
prosecutor will tell you that no
confession is needed when a terrorist
attempts to bomb a plane in front of
about three hundred witnesses where have
we gone so wrong that we believe our
security can be entrusted to judicial
processes to answer that question we
need to return to the era of FDR and
specifically to
Jackson Jackson was a giant in the
political and judicial realms the
Attorney General Roosevelt appointed to
the Supreme Court and he was later
tasked by President Truman to prosecute
the Nazis at Nuremberg when he was a
Supreme Court justice writing for the
court in a 1948 case called Chicago and
Southern Airlines vs. Waterman SS Corp
Jackson explained as follows it's a
little bit of a lengthy quote but I
think it's worth going through the very
nature of executive decisions as to
foreign policy is political not judicial
such decisions are wholly confided by
our Constitution to the political
departments of the government executive
and legislative they are delicate
complex and involve large elements of
prophecy they are and should be
undertaken only by those directly
responsible to the people whose welfare
they advance or in peril they are
decisions of a kind for which the
judiciary has neither the aptitude
facilities nor responsibility and have
long been held to belong to the domain
of political power not subject to
judicial intrusion or inquiry the
constitution of Robert Jackson like the
constitution of Andrew Jackson which is
to say the constitution of the framers
is a constitution for a free self
determining people such a people does
not surrender control of the most
fundamental questions made by any body
politic the decisions about National
Defense to officials who however
well-meaning are not politically
accountable to the people whose lives
are at stake that surrender is not the
rule of law it is the acquiescence in
judicial despotism unless we reclaim our
democratic prerogative namely placing
national security back in the control of
elected officials who answer to the
American people we shall be neither safe
nor free thank you very much
I'm happy to take questions mr. McCarthy
is someone who tried terrace and sylvain
courts you explain sort of the
progression from your support for that
now the changes of law as far as my
support for it is concerned I'd like to
hark everybody back to nineteen
ninety-three to try to clarify this a
little bit it's not like anyone back in
1993 SAT around a table and said war
crime which is it that we're we're
dealing with we had no experience to
speak of in the United States I'm not
saying that word episodes but in terms
of a systemic assault by international
terrorists particularly when they were
attacking us in our own homeland that
was not something that that the
government was prepared to deal with it
was certainly not something that our law
was planned to deal with in fact
terrorism law had to be drastically
overhauled in 1996 because the charges
that we had to bring back in nineteen
ninety-three were so paltry let me give
you one example if you successfully
committed a bombing in 1993 and people
actually were harmed or killed we had a
bombing statute we could prosecute you
and you could go to jail for life the
federal death penalty was was on the
shelf until nineteen ninety-four but you
would at least get life in prison but
let's say you committed a conspiracy to
bomb which the government was either
lucky enough or savvy enough to break up
which is what happened with the second
part of our case the first part was the
World Trade Center bombing the second
plot was a big plot against New York
City Landmarks the Lincoln in holland
tunnel the FBI is lower Manhattan
headquarters the UN by the way the next
time that someone tells you that
terrorists aren't
really irrational in 1993 they wanted to
bomb the UN because as we all know it's
a tool of American Authority and power
but but anyhow to bring such a
conspiracy where it was a plot to kill
tens of thousands of people but they
didn't carry it out we had no statute
for that so you had to bring it under
the catch-all federal conspiracy statute
which had a penalty of zero to five
years so we had very poultry charging
apparatus back back then 1996 all that
changes we have all these terrorism
conspiracy statutes and material support
statutes after 1996 you can have a
robust argument about whether we ought
to be treating this as a civilian matter
or a military matter but you could no
longer complain if you were prosecuted
that you didn't have adequate tools to
address the people who actually did get
brought into civilian court but to go
back to nineteen ninety-three for a
second the military can't operate inside
the United States it has bases inside
the United States but it can't do you
know enforcement operations because of
what what are called Posse Comitatus
restrictions as a result back in those
days the only organizations domestically
that trained for catastrophic events not
just you know terrorism events but any
catastrophe whether it was a insidious
or accidental or or what have you the
only organizations that train for that
would be the police the fire departments
the first responders etc februari 26
1993 in the middle of the day about 17
minutes after noon the World Trade
Center is bomb and what ends up
happening is what what ends up happening
whenever there's any catastrophe and
that's what happened in those days
people responded instantly without
anybody really thinking about it nobody
SAT around a table and said how should
we deal with this we didn't even know
what we were dealing with but you know
suddenly you're in an investigation and
then within about a week we had four or
five people in custody and when you have
people in custody one of the things that
happen in the Abdulmutallab case as well
when someone comes into federal custody
and they're denied bail the government
is required to indict them within 10
business days so in the blink of an eye
virtually you have a case and then
you're getting ready for trial and
you're assembling documents and you're
trying in our case we had a two-fold
problem first we were dealing with a
threat that we were utterly unprepared
to deal with and secondly we found out
right after the first bombing that they
were plotting a second bombing so we're
trying to wrap our brains around what
the threat is that we're up against it's
really pretty foreign to us and at the
same time trying to conduct another
investigation to make sure an even worse
attack than the trade center bombing
doesn't happen so I don't know that you
know you could say that I sat down in
1993 and said gee this is a crime there
wasn't any decision to make it just you
know it was wrote activity but I will
say this and I write about this in the
book um I very much wanted to believe
and did believe back in 1993 what the
Gospel according to the Justice
Department and the rest of government
was which was that it was a matter of
great importance to our reputation in
the world that we bring our enemies into
the majesty of our Bill of Rights the
Manchester majesty of our criminal
justice system vests them with all the
rights that we would give American
citizens and show the world how we
treated them versus how they treated us
I thought that would be a powerful
symbol I think the reason you believe
something like that is because it sounds
so admirable but it does when the rubber
meets the road it's not true doesn't
make any you know it doesn't make any
sense right now for example let me give
you one example and then I'll take
another question the you know we're
having this big argument about whether
we should close Guantanamo Bay because
supposedly Guantanamo Bay causes
terrorism it's a symbol of I don't know
what it's a symbol of I think it's a
symbol of George Bush and they don't
want George Bush but the theory is that
it causes terrorism because it shows
that we don't apply our ordinary rule of
law to Islamic terror
rest who by the way were was you know
but that you know by having this sort of
off the criminal justice system place
for incarcerated them where somehow
disrespecting the Muslim world and not
bringing them into the majesty of the
Bill of Rights anymore and what I always
say when I hear that is it's a couple of
things first of all it it confuses a
pretext with a cause on terrorists will
use anything as a pretext for why they
commit terrorism but terrorism isn't
caused by Guantanamo Bay what causes
terrorism is Islamist ideology and we
can have a long conversation about that
but it's a 14th century old ideology it
is not a fringe ideology it's much more
mainstream than we would would like to
believe but suffice it to say for
present purposes that that's the cause
you know the pretext is Gitmo or above
grade or Israel or you know whatever
they're using this week they'll always
come up with with with something like
that but you know the guy who I
convicted we actually convicted a number
of people in that case but the main
defendant was the blind Sheikh who was a
very powerful and legendary figure in
jihadist circles even by the time he got
here he actually is the one who issued
the fatwa the Islamic edict for the
murder of President Anwar Sadat in the
early 1980s and bin Laden by the way
credits him with having issued the fat
wad that approved the 911 attacks too so
you know we're talking about a fairly
heavy-duty guy but anyhow we brought him
into war criminal justice system we gave
him you know the nice civilian trial and
he's in a nice civilian jail he's not at
Guantanamo Bay his followers
particularly the Islamic group which is
a terrorist organization in Egypt that
he runs have committed several
atrocities including a really horrid one
in Luxor Egypt in the late 1990s where
some of the jihadists set upon
a group of over 50 tourists and brutally
murdered them with guns and knives and
left pamphlets around including
pamphlets in some of the carcasses the
corpses rather saying that they were
demanding the freedom of the blind
Sheikh now it didn't seem to impress
them very much that we had them in this
nice civilian jail after giving in the
civilian trial and the thing I think we
need to remember about that is we're
talking here in terms of who where
impressing in the world right we're
talking here about Sharia societies
where they still in force brutal whoo
dude penalties as they're called you
know stonings all all manner of stuff I
often think about you know a couple of
people coming home from the Friday
stonings you know in in Saudi Arabia
Iran or some and saying you know gee you
know what really offends make one time
I'm obey they don't even let them see a
lawyer for several months you know I
mean it how crazy is that that that you
know we think that we're going to be
impressed there is rampant illiteracy in
that part of the world in many parts of
it they think that you know studying the
Quran is the be-all and end-all of what
education needs to be I don't say that
to be derogatory I say to make a simple
point the thought that they know the
difference between whether somebody is
in a civilian jail because he's been
prosecuted on the basis of a judicial
indictment where the government proved
beyond a reasonable doubt all the
elements of the offense or that they are
in Guantanamo Bay under the laws of war
which allow us to detain until the
conclusion of hostilities you got to be
kidding me I mean they don't there's not
a chance that they would appreciate the
difference they look a lot of us don't
appreciate the difference so I don't
know who we think we're impressive sir I
think they want you to have a microphone
press mark from the location what are
the practical differences between
prosecuting k assume a military tribunal
as opposed to the civilian court and as
part of the answer will you play
interview sure let me deal with the what
the differences are first the big
difference between a civilian proceeding
and a military proceeding is the amount
of information that has to be turned
over to be defense when they wrote the
procedures for military commissions
there's a presumption in the military
commission law that if something is
classified the defense doesn't get it
the presumption in the civilian system
is that if something is relevant the
defense does get it so you're starting
out from the beginning with a situation
where the prejudice on the civilian side
is going to be toward disclosure and I
think we want it that way for cases that
are supposed to be in the criminal
justice system and we the criminal
justice system is designed for American
citizens who are presumed innocent and
you know we want to have those
protections for for people who properly
belong in it the military justice system
on the other hand is for is for
disciplining managing and and where
appropriate punishing enemies during
wartime which is a much different
purpose you think about the basic
assumptions of our system right we often
say about the civilian criminal justice
system that we would rather see ten
guilty men go free than a single person
be wrongly convicted that's the basic
conceit of our criminal justice system
we would actually rather see the
government lose in a sense that is fine
for people who belong in the criminal
justice system I don't think we would
want to change it a whit but when we're
having a national security issue when
we're at war and we have to end the
national imperative is to defeat the
enemy we can't take the position that
we'd rather see ten guilty terrorists go
free than
then you know one have his rights
trammell you know the fact of life is
you have to decide whether you're in a
national security wartime mode or a
peacetime mode because the one thing
that you cannot repeal is human error
there's going to be in justice no matter
what system you're in and what we're
talking about basically is who bears the
risk of error in peacetime when when the
civilian justice system is the is the
set of procedures that we use the
government bears the risk of every error
the defendant gets the bounce of every
ball and that's absolutely the way that
we should want it on the other hand if
you're in a wartime scenario you can't
be giving the enemy every bounce of the
ball in fact it's been the law of the
United States since I think 1798 the the
Alien and Sedition Acts the Sedition
Acts were ultimately repealed the alien
part of it or at least what I'm about to
say was not but in a declared war we are
permitted actually to arrest and detain
anybody who's in our country who is a
national of the enemy not an operative
not a soldier not somebody who's doing
anything just because the concept of
citizenship meant that you had fealty to
the enemy that was enough and has been
enough for over 200 years to be a
rationale in a declared war for
detaining people just because they were
citizens of the of the other side the
other thing about civilian versus
military trials is and and this was the
point that was really hammered home to
me day after day trying to do these
cases your incentive as a prosecutor
your duty as a prosecutor in one of
these cases is every day in almost every
minute in collision with your duty as an
official of the executive branch who has
responsibility for the National
security of the United States here's why
once you decide to prosecute a terrorist
if you made the decision that you in
good faith should bring the charges that
this person needs to be convicted these
are the worst of the worst in terms of
offenders whether you decide they're
criminals or warriors they have to be
neutralized and you know we don't have
debating society in the Justice
Department it didn't matter in 1993 or
1998 or you know whenever 2001 that I
may have had qualms about the way our
country was approaching this problem I
was a I was a prosecutor in the Justice
Department if I got told go prosecute
that guy you know the answer to that
question was well you really think we
ought to be doing this that's not that
what that's not our job there once you
make the decision that somebody should
be prosecuted your obligation is to do
everything within the law to make sure
that you convict him and that he gets as
much of a sentence as you can get
because these are the offenders who if
they get released will turn back to mass
murdering Americans I mean it's not not
rocket science about that but what does
that mean as a practical matter what it
means is when we draft indictments in
terrorism cases I don't know if you've
ever seen any of these creatures but i
think that the indictment in our case
was about 100 pages long the indictment
in the embassy bombing case i think was
over 200 pages long the reason that
these indictments are so big and
sweeping and narrative and descriptive
is because conspiracy law is very
forgiving to prosecutors in the federal
system we get all kinds of advantages
that they don't have in many of the
state systems so we can get all kinds of
hearsay into the case and background of
the conspiracy and explanation of who is
who in the conspiracy and how they how
they interrelate so what you do in order
to exploit that as a prosecutor is you
throw everything including the kitchen
sink into the indictment in the hope
that you will be able to get every piece
of prejudicial evidence that the
government has
and make sure these guys get convicted
and when I say prejudicial in that in
this sense i'm talking about properly
prejudicial all evidence that properly
comes into a trial prejudice is the
defendant that's what it's designed to
do that's the point of it well here's
the problem with that the broader you
charge a case the more things you put in
the indictment the more discovery
obligations attached for everything that
you plead in a case you turn that into a
relevant issue in the case everything
that's a relevant issue in a case allows
the defense lawyer to come in and say I
want to see all the government's files
about this this this and this and it
becomes very difficult for the
government to go into court and say well
we don't want to give you that that's
National Defense Information the rules
of civilian trials do not give the
government any advantage in terms of the
admissibility of evidence just because
something is a national defense matter
what the courts would say and I think
actually this is quite a reasonable
position is if you government decide to
bring somebody into the civilian justice
system then you have to play by the
rules and it's the rules that apply in
the civil just a civilian justice system
to every single case with the exception
of classified information in the
civilian system is that you get to
litigate before trial whether it is
admissible or not but you don't get any
advantage in the rules of evidence if
it's relevant and probative it's
admissible if it's relevant and it
passes the tests of discovery they get
disclosure of it the the defense does if
the court orders that they get
disclosure and the government doesn't
give disclosure on the court can start
dismissing counts or even dismiss the
case you may recall in the masala case
the court at least for a time struck the
death penalty notice because the
government refused to make certain
evidence and access to witnesses
available to the Sally's defense the
court of appeals reinstated the death
penalty when the government appealed
that but they also said hey look
government you know
we're going to watch very carefully how
you proceed from here on N and if mr.
masoli doesn't get the evidence that he
needs to make his defense we're going to
we keep the door open to striking count
striking the death penalty and striking
whatever else he can't defend himself on
because you won't give him discovering
what ended up happening miss ally
against the advice of all the people who
were advising him you know all his
lawyers and much the surprise of many
people pled guilty and as a result we
don't know what would have happened if
he had actually thrown down the gauntlet
we had to have a trial the trial we had
of miss Ali was just a death penalty
phase it wasn't the liability phase of
the trial where you where you find
somebody guilty or not the point is your
obligation as a prosecutor is to get
everything into the case that you can
get to assure as best you can the
outcome that the person gets convicted
and gets as much time as you can get for
him your obligation is a executive
branch official who's got some
responsibility for the national security
of the country prot that's not
prosecutors main jobs but we are I still
think of myself as a wee but prosecutors
are officers of the executive branch
it's an executive branch responsibility
to protect the American people and to
prosecute war successfully your
obligation on that score is to give the
enemy as little information as possible
because you don't want to make them a
more efficient killing machine frankly
which is what you do when you turn over
information I mean we give them we tell
them what we know and by virtue of
telling them what we know that almost
necessarily tells them how we know it
our methods and sources of information
again I think that's something we would
never want to change in the criminal
justice system for people who belong in
it they are presumed innocent and
they're entitled to that information but
when we're at war you can't be giving
the enemy your most sensitive
intelligence and telling them what you
know about them and how you know it and
what I learned the hard way over over
the years and this is a this is not an
easy lesson for Road
30 something year old prosecutor who
thinks you know I've got the biggest
case in America I'm the lead prosecutor
you haven't heard about me guess what
you find out when you go down to the CIA
they actually think there's something
that's more important than your little
trial you know whether we can keep
people alive or not and what they say to
you is we don't want to tell you this we
don't want to identify this witness
because if we tell you you have to tell
the defense if you tell the defense that
source is blown and you may be able to
now win your trial but we lose this
person who's been giving us vital
intelligence about al-qaeda we lose this
wiretap that's been very fruitful in
terms of giving us all kinds of
information we lose this trail of
terrorism financing that you're going to
disclose and tell the bad guys that we
know about it we're using that
information to try to track and map the
terrorist organization you find out
pretty quickly that there are a lot of
things that are more important to
keeping Americans alive and to
successfully prosecuting a war then
success or failure in a trial yes sir I
think they want I think they want you to
have the microphone let me say two
things I get to that and I want to get
back to your question about the
Washington Post which I slipped my mind
for a second I don't agree with with
President Obama obviously on whether we
ought to be bringing these people into
the civilian justice system but he's the
president I respect you know he won the
election this is not a shock I mean he
campaigned on this he thought that the
pre 911 way of doing things was was the
better way to go I thought that was an
important election issue and you know
it's tried to say but elections have
consequences this is the policy he wants
to install there were two things I don't
understand about his implementation of
it however one is again there's no
reason that you have to try these people
now jose padilla the so-called dirty
bomber was held for about
for years as an enemy combatant before
he was prosecuted in the civilian
justice system he tried when he was
finally prosecuting the civilian justice
system to argue to the court that the
case should be thrown out because the
government prejudiced his defense by
holding him all those years as an enemy
combatant he lost on another guy ali al
Marri who recently pled guilty I think
in the last several months was actually
held as an enemy combatant for about
seven years I think before we finally
submitted him to the criminal justice
system so the point is that it's not
like you have to have an either/or
moment right when you bring somebody
into custody we can do it the way I
don't think it's the best way to do it
but you can do it the way President
Obama wants to do it an attorney General
Holder want to do it and still exploit
the opportunity to get intelligence and
again the only thing you lose are the
statements and particularly in the
Abdulmutallab case you don't need the
statements you know he did what he did
in fact I think it's so clear that you
don't need the statements that's
probably why he's now cooperating with
the government he doesn't really have
much of a defense to the case so I don't
understand the timing part of the
implementation but here's the other
thing I don't get you know if you say
that we have to play by the rules and we
have to bring somebody into the civilian
system and we have to do all follow all
of the rules and protocols of that
system so that we can send a signal to
the world about who we are as a people
why would you bring them into the system
or say you're going to bring them into
the system and then start undermining
the system when the President of the
United States or a spokesman for the
president or the Attorney General get up
and say that this guy is going to be
convicted and executed you are
undermining the system now as it happens
I think this is utterly unnecessary I
don't want the president's hands being
tied by a criminal proceeding but this
is his idea not mine and if you're going
to play the game that way you have to
play by the rules and the rules say that
the government is not supposed to be
making statements that prejudice the
potential jury pool
and all you're doing when you do that
and they keep doing I don't understand
why they they keep doing it but all
you're doing is giving the defense the
ability to come in and either seek a
dismissal of the indictment or a lengthy
postponement until such time if ever
that they can get a fair trial now do I
think that motion will succeed no but
why why would we want to litigate it you
know that there there's a lot of things
that the government does that won't be
fatal in terms of you know the outcome
of the case but at the same time you
know there's no reason to believe me
these cases are high stakes high
pressure affairs everybody makes
mistakes in them I made I if I know
anything it's because I've made every
mistake you could make twice okay I mean
it's just that's that's just the way it
is and anyone who tells you that's not
true has never been trusted with
anything important to try that's just a
fact of life you've got to have mistakes
so why give them a freebie you know and
this is really a freebie and it's it's
it's not a good thing to undermine to
get back to what the washington post
article my sense from the washington
post article is that it's a i think it's
a head-fake for the following reason
what it says is that you know bhama is
potentially standing down on the
objection to military commissions that's
plainly not true he's already done that
on the same day people don't realize
this but on the same day that that
Attorney General Holder announced that
the 911 plotters would be getting a
civilian trial they also announced that
the coal bombers the Bombers of the USS
Cole in October of two thousand who
killed 17 members of the US Navy would
be going to a military commission so the
Obama administration has already
preserved the military commissions
they've already submitted a case to the
Military Commission and in 2009 Congress
for the third time endorsed the military
commissions so we are
military commissions and the trajectory
of what's going on here is 10 it is
trending I think toward a military
commission certainly for the 911
plotters and probably for most of the
other enemy combatants who will be tried
I don't think all of them will be tried
they'll probably be a good number of
them who can't be tried so why the big
announcement today I think the reason
for the big announcement is to suggest
that Obama the president is being
reasonable and magnanimous and staring
down his base which is going to be very
upset about this so isn't it time for
the rest of us to be reasonable and
close Gitmo and I think the game here
the ball that you ought to keep your eye
on is this is a this is a initiative the
end game of which is to close Guantanamo
Bay the idea is they compromise on
military commissions so why can't the
rest of us be big guys and compromise
about Gitmo and close that place down
here's why this is not horse trading on
you know a farm bill this is a national
security of the United States it may be
one thing in ordinary legislation to say
all right you do this and I'll do that
you give me this and I'll give you that
but in national security you don't do a
stupid thing that will endanger the
company the country because your
opposition has magnanimously agreed not
to insist that you do too stupid things
to endanger the country that doesn't
make any sense bringing these people
into this country is going to be bad on
a number of levels number one once they
are physically here there is no argument
anymore that the courts don't have
complete jurisdiction over them what I
think has stopped judges from trying to
release and some judges have tried to
release some of these guys and actually
even insistent they be brought in the
United States but what has stopped that
up until now is they are physically
outside the United States they're aliens
who don't have any right to be in the
United States and we have a statute that
says that they're excludable from the
United State
if they're if they're trained terrorists
once they're physically here all bets
are off and you'll see courts vesting
them with all not just habeas corpus
rights but by I think all the rights of
the Constitution and let's not fool
ourselves about what we're what we're
talking about here the combatants who
will be brought into this country if
they're brought in will be not only war
criminals but people who we can't try
because we know they're dangerous
because we've got all kinds of
intelligence about that or there's
interrogation information that can't be
used we're confident that that that
information is correct but it's
inadmissible in court not just in
civilian court in military court as well
these are going to be people who will be
there for detained indefinitely without
being tried nothing offends the legal
profession the legal culture and the
federal bench more than the idea that
people are in custody for however long
you know for who knows how long we'll be
in custody without having a trial and
that after a time I don't know if it'll
be weeks or months or years but I I'm
telling you bank on it if they're here
judges are going to start releasing them
and once they're physically present in
the United States there's no argument
anymore that they have to be released
someplace else well I mean let me ask
constant
I worry I have a top quality and he said
to me he he questioned the quality of
military quality the prosecutor he told
he didn't think II military a very good
job and getting high-quality judges he
also said the prosecutors were not very
good he said because they often get on
again a matter of military tribunals
that there were no none of the really
good prosecutors at justice and there
still are very prosecutors there despite
the leadership of the past year have
been attracted to going down there on
details doing that so he's really
worried about the quality let me say a
couple of things about that hunts number
one I think you know the the team that
had the KSM case was made up of both
Defense Department lawyers and Justice
Department lawyers are either two or
three DOJ lawyers on that team you know
we've had I don't think the Military
Commission system perform while I mean
first certainly in the first case it was
it was deplorable that the you know the
hamden who was bin Laden's driver and
bodyguard got what effectively was a was
time served I mean he got about a five
month sentence and then he was released
he's no longer even even in custody in
the civilian system and from the judges
i prosecuted in front of in my office
prosecuted in front of in the 90s you
know look it's not easy to convict
people but when you once you convict
them they get slammed I had a guy in my
case his meter was tickin for about 40
minutes in the whole conspiracy he got
25 years because he you know the FBI
came in and there he was mixing
explosives so yes it's performed badly I
think there's been a couple of times
frankly that the civilian system is
performed not particularly well either
but by and large the civilian system has
done a good job number one I don't think
it has to be the case that it's just
Defense Department lawyers in these
cases
there were good military judges and
there are bad military judges just like
there were good and bad civilian judges
but what I would like to take a short
opportunity to say is you know look
having done having looked at this both
ways and having lived it gun to my head
if I have to make call between civilian
system and military system I choose the
military system because of the
intelligence ramifications but ice I
started proposing in 2004 that we
stopped having this fight about should
it be military or should it be civilian
and put our heads together to design a
system that actually is tailored to this
challenge I think what you could do I
called it a national security court
other people have you know other names
for it but I think what you could do is
you could largely adopt the military
procedures but bring in regular federal
judges to try the cases on this would
have a couple of consequences one of
them is I think with due respect to the
military system you would get an
increase in the confidence of the way
these cases will handle not because the
military judges are incompetent but
because the federal judges have actually
been through this going back now to 1993
and and we ought to be exploiting that
competence the second thing it would do
is it would foster some cooperation
between the United States and our allies
now ordinarily my knuckle dragging the
end at all position is who cares what
the French think and I don't like having
to care what what the Europeans think
but we do have to care because if we
don't have a system that they will
cooperate with then they won't extradite
people who are dangerous to the United
States to that system so that we can
deal with them and if they won't what
that ends up meaning is that you're
you're outsourcing your national
security to countries that have a lot
less interest in it then you
it doesn't really matter that I think
military tribunals RPG and I think
they're perfectly fine under the
Constitution and they've been used since
George Washington you know we could talk
all day long about why they are fine and
why that why it's a system with
integrity and a good system the fact is
the Europeans and the international
community whatever that means will not
cooperate with a system that they regard
as a unilateral executive branch show
where the executive branch is the
prosecutor the judge and the jury they
they think that that is not a system
that has integrity I think they're wrong
but who cares what I think it's their
right to make that conclusion and they
have made it I think if we put federal
judges regular federal judges article 3
of the Constitution judges presiding
over these proceedings that answers that
criticism because now you have an
independent branch of government which
is which is overseeing these proceedings
I'm more sensitive than anyone I think
to the idea that we don't want judges
freelancing in national security so I
think what this would require if we were
going to implement it what would be
Congress would have to write a very
exacting national security court law
with very detailed procedures and it
would have to write in a provision that
said unless we've spelled out a right
here the right doesn't exist and courts
are not at liberty to you know use the
interstices between the provisions in
order to inflate the due process rights
that if you know if that's going to
happen that Congress has to do it but I
think if you've got that measure of
protection against judicial freelancing
there'd be a lot to be said for a system
where you had regular federal judges no
reason that Justice Department shouldn't
be a major player in this in cooperation
with the Defense Department used
military procedures and the presumptions
Congress has given us to protect
national security information but have
article three judges preside take that
to the international community and say
see
you know we're giving you an olive
branches but that we can deal with
please cooperate with our system and let
us deal with the people who are a threat
to us i think you know there's the
makings of that deal and there are even
people in the obama administration i
think who are very thoughtful people who
think it's a good idea don't tell them i
thought it's a good idea because it may
change their minds but but but i think
you know it's the right thing to do and
it would be a lot better for the country
than continuing this argument about
civilian versus military and unlike
President Bush Obama has the political
moment to get it done I mean if he
wanted to do it he's got people in the
Justice Department who would be superb
at designing it he's got a congress in
his own control and he now after i think
what's been a very hard year plus for
him sees maybe in a way that he didn't
before he was in power how difficult and
complicated this is it's something we
should do i don't know why we don't
thank you thank you